worship is leaving a mosque after
prayers and according to witnesses
deliberately targeted well he done was
yeah he actually came when the bustling
if you look at the road is a bus lane so
he actually came on the bus lane and
then he took a sharp left but he
actually went a couple of people yeah I
should run them over this was a man
driving a van yes a white van I'm like
well and from what you thought he veered
off the bus lane the bus he was on the
bus targeting people who were leaving
the mosque
yes he was leaving the mosque but what
he was it was about two minutes away
from the mosque abilify
his left so a cafe he turned left and
then all I can see is people getting hit
police and specialists medical trauma
teams arrived quickly not long after the
attack at about 12:20 in the morning by
the time they reached there were several
casualties and witnesses said some had
sustained serious injuries when police
officers arrived the suspect had been
pinned to the ground by shocked and
angry worshipers he was handcuffed and
led away police say their suspect is 48
years old but haven't released a name
though mom had actually said to people
stop hitting him and look just hold him
down and call the police
and that's what was basically done we
have a witness saying that the guy who
did what he did the driver of the van
said I did my bit which means he's not a
month earlier a this person was constant
conscious he did what he did
deliberately to hit and kill as many
Muslims as possible this attack comes
just weeks after diners were targeted in
Borough Market but this time the terror
has been directed at worshipers
finishing their Ramadan prayers there is
real shock here people have been left
stunned by what they've seen an hour
demanding urgent police action
Ashish Joshi Sky News French people
[Music]